if I said to Young Jerry who was
blabbering away doing material there's
going to be a 110 Million Dollar Payday
the final season pretty crazy you would
think you were definitely not saying no
yeah but guess what if if you're about
the money you're gonna go just so far
that's true but don't you think the
other cast members were upset with you
no we sat and talked it over you did you
went to each of them we said how do we
all feel but I
I have to say I have a sense of timing
right I I have it in jokes I have it in
my sets I have it in my career I knew
when to move to LA I knew when I was
ready for The Tonight Show I knew when I
was ready for us to do something bigger
like the sitcom I just knew and I knew
that was our moment